I see a lot of new faces for those who
don't know me I'm Shawn law what are the
data scientists here we can the advanced
tech team at TD Ameritrade and I Cole
organize this meet up with Ben Zeitlin
fermenter from anaconda as also as well
as Marcus Sherman in the back there and
a couple other folks like Logan ahlstrom
helping out but I want to also say thank
you for coming out tonight considering
that there there's snow on the ground I
expected to turn out to be a little
suspect but I everybody remember that no
it's nothing to be feared right
you just need salt everybody so as
always I'd like to thank a couple of
different groups obviously none focused
or sponsoring the meet of itself TD
Ameritrade for sponsoring the the
location of the venue I also - at the
University of Michigan for sponsoring
the food that you're enjoying right now
always the important points emergency
exits for those of you who are new and
maybe have coming report there's an
emergency exit right out here an
emergency exit right to the right of the
doors that you came in through as always
we're soliciting speakers if you got
important or interesting talks to give
please reach out to us we are planning
in April to do another lightning talk so
I'll look out for that I know somebody
else let me reach out to me today about
about giving a talk in the future also
provide feedback if there's things that
we can improve on as a group as a
community let us know and you can always
find everything you're looking for on a
github page all the slides are posted
there all the events whatnot so check it
out and regarding the talk itself today
unless you have unless your question is
quick please hold it until the end and
remember that you're in a borrowed space
so please PLEASE clean up after
yourselves any of your garbage and if
you see some hanging around help out one
of your peers I'd like to always read
the Python sort of high data code of
conduct so far data is dedicated to
providing a harassment free meeting
experience for everyone regardless of
gender sexual orientation gender
identity and expression disability
physical appearance body size
religion we do not tolerate harassment
of meeting participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
a professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds sexual
language and imagery is not appropriate
for any of our meet of events be kind to
others do not insult a put-down other
attendees behave professionally remember
that harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary joke and not appropriate
for haneda attendees violating these
rules may be asked to leave the meetup
at the sole discretion of the meetup
organizers but thank you for helping me
making big this a welcoming friendly
event for everybody and of course a
quick icebreaker maybe before I speak
about this icebreaker actually also say
that a PSA for about Python in 22 around
April 2020 I thought 2.7 end-of-life so
remember that so but if there's any time
now is the time to upgrade and go
towards Python 3 and relate to that for
our icebreaker to somebody either to
your left or to your right and tell them
if you're using Python 3 or Python 2 go
ahead real quick
[Music]
if you can
minimally take anything away from today
it is that you've met somebody that has
similar interests and that you might
have to do some convincing
perhaps I like to also highlight a this
month in data science there's this funny
or interesting I should say article that
came out which is called the 11 K hand
dataset so you can use this data set
maybe for biometrics or for gender
identity reads identity as you move
towards a more using you know your body
should identify where you are so that I
thought it was an interesting data stuff
that was made available and then there
was somebody reach out to me from my
Michigan State University of student
area here I miss them but on this he's
an assistant professor at MSU and he's
looking for postdocs so there he's a
researcher at in the computational
toxicology department so again this will
be posted or you can reach out and and
apply she's looking for a postdoc and of
course next month in January we have
Scott Seiver from the University of
Wisconsin coming to give a talk and that
is on Tuesday January 9th on the same
place at height of the talk is next
machine learning crowdsourcing and
cartoons and so with that I'd like to
introduce our speaker for today so we
have drew fosston from Chicago
drew has a PhD in physics from the
University of Chicago and he
previously was worked at GrubHub as well
as spot hero and now he is a consultant
contractor for a company called atomic
on data and he's for hire as well so
with that let's introduce drew thank you
[Applause]
the cartoons talk sounds a lot more
interesting to me so somebody's not
gonna be as well I don't know I'm gonna
be talking about time series
specifically time series experiments and
what I mean by that is the same sort of
idea that you would have if you did like
an a/b test or something where you take
a control population you take a variant
population you change something between
them can you determine like what the
effect size on the population that that
change had well how do you do that
in the case where where you're in likes
a time series plant right that the
reason I wanted to do this is because I
wanted to learn it myself so I at Spyder
we had like a radio campaign right and
so you have a radio campaign it's either
on or it's off it's not like I can just
like send it out to like these this part
of the population and not to that part
of the population and then compare how
it's different either all on or all off
one way people get around that sometimes
they find like some semi identical
markets you know and they'll maybe use
those as your control and test
populations you can do this other ways
as well
and it's not entirely tricky or anything
and there's nothing super interesting
about it necessarily but just something
I wanted to learn so so I'm gonna talk
through there's just tons of slides but
I tend to just go through them fast and
I also like to kind of give talks where
it's like
pretty I was a basic but like really
builds from the entire ground up so I'm
hopeful that even if you're like a super
expert in like time serious stuff I know
there's lots of you know sort of
financial people that this is like their
job so if that's boring - I'm sorry but
the so I'm going to talk about like
typical experimentation in data science
what time series experiments are I'm
gonna create some data that we can play
with talk about Arriba algebra and
forecasting with the staff models
package which is typically in Python an
easy way to do ARIMA forecasting and
then actually modeling like
interruptions with pie mc3 which is an
MCMC library that does simulations so
about me
that's my wife and kids they're from the
oh my wife's from the Toledo area so we
have family Christmas this weekend so
came into town dropped him off and then
came up here so as Sean said I was at
the University of Chicago I did a PhD in
physics looking for dark matter so I had
to be like a miner and go down into like
an active nickel mine with a bunch of
bunch of Canadian miners which is really
neat because that's where our experiment
had to be it was like a mile on the
ground so does neat I most recently been
at spot zero which is if you're familiar
with grub hub it's just like grub hub
for parking it's the basically the same
company so it was really fun to go from
one to the other cuz I got all my ideas
a grub hub and then I went and tried to
build them at spot hero so I left there
about a little over a month ago now and
I'm doing my contracting insulting and
in the Chicago area as for you if I say
something like hypothesis testing and a
be testing is that typically sort of
ring a bell and everybody like yeah
that's that's cool I understand um same
deal like timeseriesforecasting
something called my Remo model no okay
cool that's good if I were to talk about
like probability distributions about
like a Poisson distribution something
like that it's cool anybody happen to
know off the top of their head if
something is Poisson distributed and say
time what is the distribution of the
time between events what's that the
exponential is correct yes so that's
something we'll use and then if I said
Markov chain Monte Carlo anybody okay
all right I just kind of wanted to get
two nods or head shakes
okay so typical experimentation you have
a and B you have a control group which
is going to get your normal website you
have your variant population they're
going to change the bar from red to
green and we want to see if that
actually change in something like
conversion rate let's say so conversion
rate was 23% normally they give them a
green bar and for some reason people
click on that green bar more and then
you want to kind of measure the
difference between another 23 and that
the 37 and so usually you run these
things concurrently so that you meeting
you know at the same time so that you
can keep all of the unnecessary
variation controlled so in Python it's
pretty easy you have a beta distribution
when we're talking about conversion rate
a beta distribution where you can draw
from a measured number of successes
which would be something like
conversions a measure number of failures
which would be like the total number of
visits minus the conversions right and
in population be the same deal so you
have like do I have it written here oh
no I don't know I'll show you in a
second and then what you can do is you
can just draw from those two populations
a group of let's say 10,000 samples just
measure the difference between those two
and then look at what the distribution
of that difference is and so an example
would be if in population a I had 100
observations and 20 successes of be a
conversion rate of like 20% and
population B I got 50 observations 15
successes which would be a conversion
rate of 30% like is that enough to
actually tell the difference between
these two populations
well you can actually sample from this
compare those two populations against
each other to actually determine what
the effect sizes and turns out that to
95% confidence it's between minus 4% and
plus 25% is the effect rate right so the
95% confidence I cannot say with this
many observations that it's so sure
caused a lift but that's why you then
would get up to like 60 or 70 or 80
observations right the more you get the
tighter this little green bar becomes
and then you can actually tell the
difference right and so that is entirely
done with just that code there which is
pretty straightforward just a couple
lines of code not too bad um so some
experimentation is easy right I don't
have the slightest idea why somebody
taught keep the shift key for a B
testing but there you go some
experimentation is hard and I love this
gift an example being what we're going
to talk about now which is like here's a
time series forecast right and let's
suppose at this sort of gray bar here
that we introduced some sort of change
and the population like maybe we
launched like an ad campaign or
something right and so the blue here is
the observed the green is the forecast
and you can see that as you get farther
into the future like this is the future
here and you're forecasting this that
your error bars of what you actually
think the forecast is is going to get
wider and wider and wider right so so it
becomes more and more difficult to
actually tell if this effect that's
happening is actually from what I
introduced or if it's just from normal
variation in the data because normal
variation is pretty wide right that's
what these error bars say that's normal
variation yeah you have a question yeah
sure
and I mean presumably this forecast here
I mean actually no because this is from
a blog post by a guy named Tom
augsburger which is he's awesome
he definitely did like this is based on
like just using pandas because he's one
of the contributors to pandas using
pandas and as well as as stats models to
do time series forecasting and he
definitely was doing all those you know
stationarity tests and everything else
so in a world like this it becomes kind
of hard to do a/b testing right so you
might think that so what you actually do
is maybe you have like here's your
baseline this is your normal population
you're introduced some sort of change
and it actually changes whatever the
event rate is and that actually looks
decently measurable I could probably do
something about that you know so you
know maybe maybe this isn't so bad
you know you simply just apply variation
in time measure before versus after and
we can actually tell what's going on so
maybe we're a little bit relieved right
now I would say more more common it
would be something like this well ignore
the the red line for a minute like
there's no way there's like a change in
that time series right like this there's
like 15 observations here you know and
now they're gonna say oh yeah we we
introduced some legislation and doesn't
say on here but let's just say you know
we see like a 10% drop and whatever this
is no way so so you could say yeah like
you know simply you know apply a
variation in a moment of time and just
like measure you know so yeah that's the
that's that's how something like that
would be so let's give this a try we're
gonna make some data that we could run
through some sort of model okay so I'm
gonna think about transactions and so
transactions are maybe even something
like like bus arrivals the classic
example of bus arrivals buses are
Poisson distributed in time which means
I hypothetically at least that if a bus
is supposed to arrive every five minutes
you know that's your sort of expectation
value is five minutes Poussin also has
the the add a characteristic that the
the
the variance in that population is also
five minutes that kind of defines the
Poisson so we're gonna start with a
homogeneous was on point process point
process meaning these are points
distributed randomly on time like bus
arrivals Poisson means it follows some
sort of distribution that looks like
this lambda is my mean and my variance T
is the amount of time the expectation
value of the number of events I should
expect to see and an amount of time T is
just equal to lambda times T right and
the probability that n of T is exactly
equal to lowercase n just any number is
is this and that's on the distribution
area here that's the PDF of that
homogeneous just means that lambda is a
constant right it's just the same all
the time
and as as we got with our quiz earlier
the differences between events and time
are exponentially distributed with a
factor of 1 over lambda I'm going to use
that fact here to actually create a
homogeneous was on point process this is
all commentary here this is literally
like to three lines of code right and
all you do is you randomly sample some
Exponential's from an exponential
distribution with some sort of rate and
you just commit a literally sum them and
so I have one that's maybe at like two
minutes and then another one that's like
four minutes later and so that would be
like two minutes and then six minutes
would be the second event and so on and
so forth right and that is a homogeneous
was on what process but events are
really constant in time and so can we
actually vary it at lambda that's what's
called a not a modulus what's on my
process which is where lambda is allowed
to vary over time so that might seem
decently straightforward but it's not
exactly the easiest things you'd like
simulate in the real world
except for with complete laziness which
is you just make homogeneous point
process with some sort of lambda let's
call it lambda H which is the the
highest lambda that I actually want and
my non-homogeneous point was on point
process right so it's the highest
instantaneous rate that I want in the
whole population and then I'm going to
attach a random number between 0 and 1
to every single point in the homogeneous
on-point process and I'll show you what
that means in a second here and I'm
going to define some sort of rate
function R such that that that's between
0 and 1 so it's kind of a probability
such that R of some T is equal to 1 when
for any T for which this lambda is the
maximum lambda and it's you know 0 when
it's 0 right so and then discard any
points in the homogeneous on point
process for which this constant is
actually greater than that are values so
in picture form here is some data this
is a homogeneous Poisson point process
maybe I think 500 points or a thousand
points or something like that
there's a whole bunch at 0 and a whole
bunch you know at 1 so if I were to
smoosh these all down you can imagine
that would make a like a like a
histogram and it would that histograms
heights would be so it looked something
like that I guess if it we're a
histogram although that's a line chart I
then have this sort of rate function
here which says basically at time T
minutes you know my rates actually kind
of small whereas actually at time T 20
the race a lot higher right so maybe
this is overnight this is like peak rush
hour or something like that right so you
just literally define a curve that looks
like this right so it might just be a
sign where it's like overnight it slow
during the day it's high the night slow
day it's high and it just goes like that
right and you just throw out all those
points above there so all those red
points and now you have a process that
looks like this this is a
non-homogeneous Poisson
process so you can see that it's you
know sort of a low rate and then it kind
of gets higher as it goes out here but
the points there are homogeneous or
Poisson distributed and instantaneously
they have a certain right so so building
this also not hard I just filled my
homogeneous Poisson point process
assigned some random numbers and then
apply some sort of thinning function
like that that red curve there and then
just threw out everything that's less
than that right so cool here's my
thinning function let's say this is
overnight this is during the day
overnight during the day and this is
maybe the weekday this is like weekends
right same deal same deal same deal same
deal this kind of looks like what
transactions would look like let's say
it's five here or something like that
and overall there's maybe some sort of
trend right it's we're doing better
we're getting more customers it's
growing in time right so this is what up
is on I'm not a modulus on point process
would looked like which really really
really does look like you know the
transactions data at spot here okay and
that's right kitties so so let's talk
about ARIMA algebra ARIMA algebra is
basically ARIMA is is is what you would
often use to do forecasting it means
autoregressive they are integrated i
moving average MA and it looks like this
and my whole life I've looked at this
and thought that's that's too
complicated I don't understand what's
going on there I'm just gonna literally
throw it at stats models and let it do
its thing right turns out I couldn't
actually do that for this because I
actually wanted to add some variation to
this model and so I actually had to
learn what the heck was going on so this
is me at the beginning of this exercise
just a existential dread of and I don't
understand what that is at all but turns
out it's actually decently
straightforward Anna Ramah model is
defined by three numbers P D and Q these
are like the order of the auto
regressive integrated moving average
parts right and we can simplify this
down to
there's just this mathematical operator
in there autoregressive world which I'm
going to call Phi sub P and it acts on b
b is like a lag operator basically B
times X of T would give me X of t minus
1 it just steps the time series back 1
okay so that's the autoregressive part
this is the integrated part this table
here is just defined as 1 minus B to the
D we'll see that in a second and then
that's all equal to the moving average
part which is this little guy here and
then that's times the error in the
observations and a sort of time so if
you look at on a regressive 5 P is just
defined as this it's it's just 1 minus
Phi 1 times the backtick operator minus
Phi 2 times the back to copper R squared
minus 1 all the way up to P right so
often if you have an AR 1 model it would
just be this part right here it's just 1
minus Phi 1 B right that's not so hard 1
minus Phi 1 B let's if it's AR 1
it's ignore those two it's just 1 minus
Phi 1 B times X of T equals epsilon T
right so that would be X of t minus Phi
1 X of t minus 1 equals M plumb to you
which is literally just an equation that
you can solve not so hard
integrated looks like this 1 of minus B
to the D power you just take D
consecutive lags yeah and moving average
looks like this it looks exactly like
the auto regressive one except for just
with a different a different thing
lambda instead and it hits on the
epsilon instead of the time so you can
actually generalize this to a seasonal
by adding three more components which
look the exact same it's just there with
capitals and there's this little S here
and all that s does is it's just apply
that to that be its
literally be to the s power right and so
a seasonal autoregressive this phi p is
again just like well that's an operator
but the phi one would be just like a
constant and I'm gonna solve for and
remember that actually let's let's use
the this one because the pink showed up
a little bit better so the theta Q is 1
minus theta one BS so B to the s power
you know and then the second term would
be B to s all right and then all the way
out to be P s right so this is like a
fourth order seasonal that would mean
that your first term is Theta 1 B to the
fourth so I want four lags back your
second term would be B to the 2's which
would be eight legs back right so this
allows these lags to be non-consecutive
in time right so that's what the
seasonal does for me right
and so here's your model that is a
seasonal ARIMA it at least color-coded
it maybe doesn't look so bad but the end
of the day all you're doing is whatever
the model is you could literally just
plug in what these these mean here and
all you are left with is just an
equation and you can kind of solve
equations and then once you have an
equation what you're trying to do is
you're trying to fit for what are these
values here right that's it that's it's
so it's literally just kind of a like a
least squares fitting problem right
which isn't so bad so an example being
in a Rima one one oh you have five one
be na blue one be XT theta zero be theta
0 is just 1 right because it's 1 1 0
that's what they define one means that's
what Knobble one means you just carry
these things through B times B is
actually equal to B squared right
because I backtick once in the night
back kick again so it works out to just
be this equation right so if I come in
and I have knowledge of what yesterday
or two days ago value was and
yesterday's value was and maybe I
observe what today's value is I can
actually measure what
Salani and then I can do that again for
tomorrow and do that again for tomorrow
and you could just keep stepping forward
in time right so that's what that's what
it's so that's awesome that support
casting with ARIMA I took an aside and
added some notes I gave this talk
actually on Monday but I wanted to kind
of talk a little bit that a rhemas
actually want your time series the the
errors in your time series to be
normally distributed which often aren't
like in our case they're not because
they're distributed right so you can do
what's called a box Cox transformation
which is literally just this formula
here I only say this because you'll have
to do this when you're doing forecasting
oftentimes and that's really easy
because you just import it from Sify and
box-cox on your time series literally
gives you the trance the the transformed
time series and in some sort of
exponential yeah and finds you like this
minimum value right and the way you
actually find this minimum value of you
want to do it by yourself is you would
just pick a bunch of exponents and you
would figure out what the transformation
is for each one of the exponents and you
just pick the one that has the minimum
variance that's you know variance
variance from normal whatever it is all
you're doing is just minimizing that and
yes this does that automatically another
thing you need to know with forecasting
is these autocorrelation functions which
that's this is these are the tea leaves
that you read when you're doing time
series forecasting so I borrowed this
from again from Tom augsburger who I
mentioned earlier which is just using
these stats models plot ACF and plot P
ACF but it's this little thing that
spits out everything all together and so
here is for instance a simulated data
set and this is what the autocorrelation
and partial auto correlation plots look
like right and the name of the game and
forecasting is we want to get rid of
this this little gray bar here is
basically noise this is like I can't
tell the difference between this and
zero and I want this to be zero what I
mean by that is I want this to be white
noise I want to just very around zero
and have no characteristic to it
whatsoever
any one of these dots that's outside of
this bar basically means there's some
component to it that's not quite white
noise right and so what I want to do is
I want to get rid of that okay and so
that's what the tea leaves are so ACF
being so high for so long you just kind
of learn these things as you go I guess
but it suggests that an integrated model
is needed for this particular thing the
other thing that would tell me an energy
well there's multiple things one there's
definitely a trend to this that's
usually what you kind of do differencing
is to get rid of that trend and so that
would suggest I probably want an
integrated term so with this
autocorrelation here also you can
measure stationarity as you mentioned
before there's something called an
adjusted Dickey fuller test which will
tell you basically if there's a unit
root which has something to do with
cessation area if there is no unit then
it's stationary otherwise it's not this
value here is a p-value sorry it's a
p-value and so if that number were less
than 0.05 I guess then I would be able
to say yeah this is stationary the fact
that that number is not less than 0.05
means it isn't stationary which means I
need to get rid of that which is what I
would use like a high term for an early
model so going back to our partial
autocorrelation here we have these these
spikes that happen at 7 and again at 14
and you can also see them over here in
the autocorrelation it's just higher at
7 and 14 seems to suggest there's some
sort of seasonal trend with like a
seven-day component to it right every 7
days the the trend repeats right so if
you remember from our our little rate
like thinning function that we defined
earlier that it was like Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday
this and then it went down for Saturday
Sunday right so that's what this is
picking up okay
so that's gonna suggest it I want some
sort of seasonal term with like I said
with s equals seven here so let's just
try a seasonal remo with like zero one
zero one meaning I need D to be greater
than zero so why not one s is equal to
seven I know and I don't know I just
picked one zero one here because
sometimes you pick other ones it just
doesn't actually converging it doesn't
give you any model whatsoever so to do
this real easy with stats models
something called sorrow max which sounds
like a villain from Lord of the Rings
but you just pass it a time series give
it your order and your seasonal order so
zero one zero one zero one seven that's
it
and then you fit the model and then it
will spit out some sort of the residual
will spit out some sort of actually I
think this result spit out some sort of
summary and it will have all sorts of
things to it this right here is called a
I see which isn't gay information
criteria which basically says is this a
good fit or not but you're punished for
overfitting so the more terms I add to
it the worse that number will get if of
course the the log likelihood of that
fit doesn't over compensate for adding
those terms so two models that behave
the exact same and predict the same one
having two and one having three terms to
it the two will have a better a I see
better eating lower so in this case 1395
if I were to compare this to another
model and it had like a 1200 I would say
that model is better right so also spit
out here is my capital Phi one and my
capital yeah
theta one here and so here's the their
best guess on that is basically one with
no standard error and minus one with no
standard error basically so that's cool
it at least converged on a really very
specific answer and if I were to look at
what our time series looks
like now with this applied to it that
looks pretty white noisy right it's not
so bad it's not white noise though
because you can see that I still have a
couple dots that are outside my blue and
I really have one dot here that's
outside of the blue here and so that's
just to me there's there's something
more going on right so I actually want
to add more terms than just this to get
rid of everything right so this being
way far down but all the rest of them
being pretty much nothing suggests
probably a moving average because it
turns out that like a moving average one
is memoryless which means that it
remembers like the error on this last
step but forgets about it two steps
beyond and that's not true of an
aggressive like it keeps its memory
along and it kind of just decays the
farther out we get so that would suggest
I at least want to add one there this
also sort of suggests that maybe I want
an autoregressive term here because the
second term and just believe me you can
try things if you want
let's try in fact a two on one because
it turns out that that one worked really
really well much better a I see here's
my values that I get here
that's okay it looks real real real good
all of these things are within the blue
I think that's a real good model oh yeah
no so these were the two that I had
before yeah actually they are they're
the same that they're the same
oh that they're close to one yeah right
yeah yeah you're right and I hadn't even
thought about that so so that's true
that's weird though well that probably
would suggest to me that I want one of
those not the other problem because I
definitely want a seasonal term I know
that but so probably over over
compensating having both of them is what
there's a jewel yes yeah so yeah and so
that's the white noise that we want
that's pretty good model so forecasting
with ARIMA I don't know what Gobert is
but I love it now so the whole of
forecasting with ARIMA and I I don't
like the outcome of what's about to
happen but this is what you would do you
would maybe box-cox transform some
things you would get some predictions
out of our our forecast that we saw a
couple slides earlier turn those
predictions into the proper original
sort of scale that I had and just plot
that and so here's your yeah here's your
forecast versus your so your observed
versus your forecast you can see that
there's it's not terrible and that it
kind of trends the right way and yeah
gray bar is getting wider as I go out
farther in time this is like where I'm
forecasting from right here really
really don't like that I'm pretty much
missing the weekdays all the time like
I'm definitely under estimating the
weekdays so I would want to explore this
more but that's kind of the output of
what a forecast model would look like
right cool
so that's forecasting in a really
interrupted time series so now this is
what we're actually trying to talk about
here is I want to introduce at some time
T some variation right and that
variation maybe has an effect size beta
meaning if my my time series like if I
was getting like a hundred transactions
normally like on a Monday let's say and
let's say beta was was like of size 20%
I might expect that I'd get 120 next
Monday or something like that right so
and that would be because I got a lot
more a lot more users because of a radio
ad or something like that
right and so that's what I'm wanting
measure is I want to figure out how
strong is beta right I called it beta
throughout I was using this textbook in
fact he has this and I know you can't
really read this but an Omega zero is
what he has it called here though so he
basically has a a model here
is by the looks of it a ma one model
right because he has a no it's not it's
an no no I did look
oh no it's not anything it's it's it's a
it's it's it's a random walk model was
actually what it is but what he does
with it is he measures what would oh
make a zero B to actually match this
time series here versus here right and
with two different kinds of models and
it gets like - one and a half percent
basically and both of them so hooray
like that's one and a half percent lower
than that like and yeah like with like
pretty pretty good you know T values and
all that jazz so I'm skeptical but yes
so that's what that is and all of this
is is literally as we said earlier just
doing our normal like least squares sort
of regression and and this is my
equation for the for the model right so
in our world we're going to start with a
simple time series because I don't want
to do something super complicated so I'm
just gonna have my non-homogeneous
Poisson point process just being a thing
that increases with time after 365 days
like my transactions double or something
like that right so it's just gonna look
like a growing I'm going to add like a
small effect size at some start time
which I call treatment start and I'm
gonna say so the time series starts on
March first the treatment starts on on
May 1st so in May first we launch a
radio ad right and I'm going to pause it
at the moment just to for illustration
purposes the effect size of this radio
ad is exactly 10% right so if I had
expected 100 before I get 110 and this
is just messy pandas just to make a time
series that is what it was before and I
just add some some data to and then I'm
going to throw that at my ARIMA model
just to see how it works turns out a 0 1
1 model works really well for this guy
and get my predictions and just plot
them so this would be our data set we're
gonna work with so here's your data
here's what the forecast is of that
these are the error bars of the forecast
there's a 95% confidence bands one two
or outside of my confidence bands prob
about a hundred terms there and it looks
you know five percent you know that's
alright
red is with my effect in it right so the
idea is if this time series were to just
keep going on in time I should probably
be able to measure this much in effect
here right and so I'm gonna like make
one observation and say wow that numbers
kind of big and then second observation
annum is really big and then what is the
best fit value for this beta that would
give me these values here okay so that's
what I'm gonna do here this is with PI
mc3 so this is probably small or at
least you in the back does this just
look horrible
yeah well you can find the site later so
when I MC 3 what you do is you define a
model and and you define some variables
in that model that you seed with some
distribution to them and then what it's
going to do is it's gonna pass through
like thousands let's say of passes
through here and it's gonna sample from
those from those distributions and
eventually find out like actually this
is where that distribution should be I
started it at zero with the standard
deviation of two but it turns out that
like when all said and done theta kind
of shifts over here and settles on to
some good value but it gives you like
the error bars around that so not only
am I going to get like theta but I'm
gonna get like my confidence band around
theta once I fit my model so this is my
ARIMA theta here right this is a zero
one one model that's my theta from the
final one there right and then I have
this beta term here so the beta term
okay so first of all
why mc3 is built on top of Theano rest
in peace' Theano is just like a way of
doing tensors and stuff and they use it
for deep learning but I'm just using it
for tensors tensor is just a fancy way
of saying a vector but in more space
than that but in this case they're
literally all just vectors so it's
unfortunately I couldn't just use
vectors this switch value here is just a
case statement it says if this thing is
true use that first one if it's not true
use the second one right and so I'm
going to create a time series and that
time series is just Y it's my normal
time series unless of course Y switch is
false in which case it's gonna be Y
minus y times beta right where beta is a
number sampled from this distribution
okay so and that switch is just is just
the cutoff point of when the times that
the experiment starts right so
everything to the left when the
experiment starts is why everything
after the experiment starts is gonna
have this Y minus beta here right so if
I only through data at this before the
experiment I actually would never be
sampling on beta and never be figuring
out anything better about beta and what
I would get out the other end of this
would be that my best guess for beta is
a normal distribution centered at zero
with standard deviation two because I
haven't given it in any observations to
update that that understanding right so
this here is my ARIMA model so this is
why I had to learn how to do or emu
algebra because what you are going to do
in this model here is you're literally
going to just skip ahead here looping in
Theano also is weird but it's basically
it's it's this it says I'm going to give
it a function called calculate next and
that's going to output some epsilon
value and I'm gonna be going through and
calculating my episode I'm gonna
calculate my error terms as I go I'm
gonna seed it with some initial number
which I'm going to say is zero and and
then I'm going to pass it through this
function and every time I go into this
function I'm going to say that the error
is equal to the current value of y minus
yesterday's value of y minus theta times
epsilon which is actually yesterday's
value of Epsilon right and how I derived
this equation is from my ARIMA algebra 1
minus B times y of T 1 minus theta B
times epsilon T you work all that out
and epsilon T is equal to this function
here which is that option there right if
this were a different model like a 1 1 1
model it would have different terms here
and this would look different right so
this is very specific for a 1 1 1 model
I era 0 1 1 model and I used that
particular model just because I passed
it through stats models and also with
the website initially weighted moving
average yes I mean that is literally
what it is it's growing exponentially
with time and otherwise it's just like a
yep yeah so basically then you pass this
model here you say with build model
equals my time series when the time
series starts and I'm gonna give it like
a number of treatment observations so
I'm gonna say like I'm two days into my
into my treatment I'm two days like pass
like like I'm on May 3rd now I've
observed May first and I've observed May
2nd ok and so I have those two those two
observations let's go back here I have
these two observations here boom and
boom right and I'm gonna say hey what do
I think beta is now right before I had
those I think beta 0 with some sort of
unknown confidence now I think beta is
point 2 this is a bug I don't I I wasn't
able to figure this out
this should be point 1 and I swear to
you on the whole Drive over here it was
point 1 and then I was like trying to
update the slides like just now and it
kept being point to it I don't know why
so I'm gonna try to fix that but it was
really great and it was like zeroing
right around this and I mean like that's
crazy zeroing and I don't trust how like
after 2 observations it's between 18 and
22
you know like come on
but theta is really good it's actually
pretty well the exact same theta value
that I got from my stats model model
before right so except for now I
actually have a spread to it like it's
not just like Oh theta is equal to minus
0.8 it's actually it's somewhere between
minus 0.8 3 and minus 0.8 1 you know to
95% confidence which is really cool this
noise here is exactly what you want to
see that means that that's that's that's
the tingling that means it's working
right so that's the pi mc3 is doing its
job so i've now made with this model
here an effect size observation right so
how good is my how good is my radio ad
it's that good with this confidence
right so that's actually really cool
because that's exactly what you would do
with a an a/b test where you're trying
to measure beta how why did I use beta
because beta is the district yeah
um you're trying to measure like what
the effect size is between the control
and the variant right and that's exactly
what we did here except for some time
seriously which is cool so hooray
celebration that works pretty well and
that is all my notes it was like 79
slides which is amazing so there this is
all my stuff again this right now is
here but you said you're gonna host
things as well so you can just probably
just clone that error fork fork this
eventually but I'm gonna try to figure
out that bug otherwise looks pretty good
so cool thanks
[Applause]
yeah at the beginning of the you put off
learning um your algebra was kind of
your criteria or justification for using
it instead of just down sampling and
down sampling and taking an aggregate
function like what made you did the
granularity I wanted to have something
that was general enough that it could
actually like I could throw it at any
sort of any sort of time series and
actually get like a good estimate of
what that beta is um because usually the
time series looks like kind of what I
had before
which would be like a seasonal seven
term you know whatever in which case
that function in the PI MC three would
be really ugly and complicated which is
why I simplified it but I'm not sure I
mean there are a lot of other
forecasting methods and I recognize that
I have a little bit of a Frankenstein's
monster here of using like a Rima which
to some extent is a pretty what's the
word freak frequentist statistics sort
of way of doing things and then I like
throw like Bayesian ways of doing things
and that's just because I wanted to use
by mc3 ultimately at the end there's
lots of forecasting models that do you
know forecasting using more Bayesian
techniques as well I just started doing
this with a Rima and had a book that was
doing it in a Rima and then I was like
well I actually want to get a little bit
better of an estimation than that so
that's why I use PI MC 3 so it's a
little bit all over the place there's
more of the data so you can use all of
that instead of sampling yeah I I'm not
entirely clear on one like the down
sampling I know what down sampling means
I just don't know what it would mean
necessarily in this context and you like
taking it like or yeah
so you don't get the same granularity if
that's what you get there right right I
mean I I definitely assume that like
after and I don't trust this right now
as it is I think there's a bug in there
but like after two days to be able to
say yeah that's good and then like on
the third day come back and get an
updated observation like I think if I
were to just like draw like a line
through it sort of thing I wouldn't
necessarily get that granularity
although if you look at the forecast
that comes out the other end with a zero
one one model is just a line yeah so no
I have not
have you like for another black Steve or
receding that's like it looks pretty
similar but they like the idea is like
well it's pretty hard to find like lon
CD or one state so we just match exactly
Tran in our yep state for example and
then we see okay after like this and
like started yeah it's just like
synthetic like speed like I was going to
be right so it looks kind of the same
idea so we just wondered yeah yep my
initial thought on that was like oh well
this would be cheaper though but like in
this case no the the variant is still
the one city and the rest of the
population is not control oh yeah yeah
and that's that's why this seems scary
to me in general like oh you know
there's a holiday and I didn't actually
take it into account forecasting it
correctly and oh yeah I was just
measuring the holiday not the radio ad
you know yeah that as well so and the
rest is you won't see this like the days
that are what has wanted you you had
campaign and the rest of the day that
you didn't
launch the campaign oh yeah yeah so
that's that's another right so I think
what you mean is like actually very it
like each day and I turn it on turn it
off turn it on turn it off and be able
to like really get oh that's what you
mean okay you lunch you know that you
launch the campaign from the seven day
yeah I know and then you just look like
those day as one and you aggressively
doubting my mm-hmm ARIMA X is what he's
saying yeah oh yeah actually and that is
what I was using but I I wasn't using
the X at all so I was using Sarah max
but it wasn't with those exogenous
updates to it at all no I could yeah
nothing more to add to that but yeah
yeah well because I've always been
afraid of like all the algebra of this
in the past like what I would have done
in that case would have been said ah
just take the Mondays and have a
time-series forecast for Mondays and and
the seasonality there would be 365 let's
say or something like that and then take
the Tuesdays and have another one like
that and then just combine all those
together and I've done that I'm pretty
sure you can add multiple seasonal terms
here because that pretty well like I
mean it just you know it seems pretty
pretty commutative where I could just
keep adding other terms which I'm around
however I want it would be fine so and
you're not in your head yet so the
answer to that is yes you could totally
do that
now with the with stats models like
seasonal ARIMA wasn't even like
available in like the master version of
stats models until like the last year
which it's crazy to me it's always been
available in our land
so you've got that going for you but so
if you're gonna use one of the built-in
packages I don't think they sort of
allow you to do multiple seasons but
that's why you learn how to actually do
it from scratch any other yeah I mean I
would literally piece them together by
piecing together and like eventually
like oh here's your here's your Mondays
here's your Tuesdays just like have
those data frames of forecasts and I
would just literally append them and
then sort it and then be like oh look
there's yeah I mean yes but also
remember like our like a I see where
we're like hey let's get the minimum a
number of terms that describes this time
series and if I were to say split it up
into seven independent time series each
of which is an ARIMA let's say one one
one or whatever right which has two two
parameters to it I now have like 14
parameters describing my whole like time
series like one like two parameters for
Mondays and 250 and that seems probably
like overfitting to me so I would want
to probably figure out how to do like
some sort of aggregated AIC or something
like that to make sure that that
actually is an OK model to do but yeah
that's just I mean I've feels just like
a hierarchical model in that case right
which is basically to say you have an
extra term which defines the hierarchy
which in this case would be I have a
model for Monday and I have a model for
Tuesday and that's Monday and Tuesday or
the hierarchy all right so I would
that's probably also where I go with
that so with that I want to thank drew
because now I have to improve my time
series game as well as my life and my
mean games you know the gifts yeah
yeah that's that's what I'm actually
proud of and I want to point out real
quick this sort of unrelated to this
before we thank you is AG in the back
had a request you want to put up your
hand a J so if anybody has any expertise
in using random forests I think J could
use the extra eyes on that but and
somebody left their hat no thanks thank
you
so with that let's now give you a round
of applause
[Applause]